i've been using the new ipad air 5 for
two weeks now and i think i finally
gathered my thoughts on where it stands
within the ipad lineup as well as how it
compares to other android tablets on the
market so i'm just gonna go ahead and
call it what it is a stop gap product
yes of course it's an excellent update
since the price is still the same 599
dollars as before and you're getting a
bunch of spec upgrades and features but
i've got to admit that it feels like
something major is missing and speaking
of those upgrades the biggest one is of
course the new m1 chip which is the same
one that's inside of the ipad pro and
it's much faster than the a14 in the
previous ipad air 4. for example looking
at the multi-core performance we have a
huge improvement of 69
which is gonna matter for all the
high-end productivity apps that require
lots of multi-core performance but the
biggest difference is when we take a
look at the graphics performance with
the m1 ship being 77 faster than the old
a14 and this right here is what matters
the most because a lot of different apps
and games depend on the gpu performance
so as far as the performance aspect
we're definitely getting a big upgrade
this time around but then when we look
at the overall design it's essentially
unchanged so if you take all of those
upgrades and consider the fact that the
600 price tag for the new ipad air 5 has
not changed i'd say that this is
actually a pretty good update the new
ipad air is making life pretty tough for
the android tablet market especially if
you consider resale value which the
ipads always excel at when we start
comparing the ipad air 5 and the current
ipad pro we start to see just how much
better the ipad pro is in terms of value
but the absolute most important feature
of all is actually the 120 hertz pro
motion display technology which is
exclusive to the ipad pro so if you take
all of those advantages including
doubling the storage then i'd say that
if there is any way you can possibly get
your hands on another 150
to buy the ipad pro on sale instead of
the new ipad air 5 then absolutely do it
because you will not regret it and you
won't feel like your m1 ship is being
limited by the 60hz refresh rate of the
ipad air but now the last thing i want
to mention is the future ipad air model
which i think is coming in the fall of
2023 and i believe that the ipad air 6
will be the first ipad to use a new oled
display so if you can wait until the end
of 2023 then that will actually be a
pretty nice upgrade in terms of display
quality as well as other upgrades like
the m2 chip and more